bom nesse preciso momento que muitos de
vós e mesmo se não houver pela primeira
vez acredito que muitos estejam a
formular um pensamento uma opinião sobre
mim o que eu vim aqui falar que eu tinha
que fazer porque estou numa cadeira de
rodas
como é que eu vivo a minha vida numa
cadeira de rodas ou se calhar muitos
vocês não acharam a prepotência catarina
achar que estou a pensar nela
mas à parte isso é verdade é que todos
nós temos um pensamento sobre o outro e
ninguém sabe o que realmente o outro
está a pensar sobre nós mas durante
muito tempo na minha vida e acredito que
alguém que se identifica comigo o peso
da opinião do outro sobre mim o que eu
achava que o outro e achar sobre mim
tinha muito peso na minha vida e às
vezes até achava que fazer esta ou outra
coisa porque achava que o outro e achar
estou aqui o mas só quando você as
identifica com esta forma de pensar
tenho duas boas notícias o contru pensa
sobre nós o culto julga o sumo sobre nós
é só o outro pensa sobre nós só mais
nada e para além disso o que vocês
pensam sobre mim o que eu penso sobre o
acesso
nesse caso o que vocês pensam sobre mim
diz muito mais sobre vocês do que sobre
mim porque vocês não sabem nada como
vocês não sei nada
portanto diz muito mais sobre como vocês
reagiriam a minha situação do
questionamento o que é minha situação e
espera agora eu estou a pensar ou não
porque na realidade não sei
tantas refeições assim logo à partida e
vou explicar ao longo da minha conversa
com vocês porque eu eu eu acredito que
todos nós estamos nesta vida muito em
busca de algo que nos completa que nos
realiza nos faça feliz e acho que esta
busca quase inconsciente às vezes nós
queremos sempre um carinho na comparação
com o outro com uma vida do outro o
outro é mais fluência certeza o outro
que não tem tantos problemas o outro tem
mais dinheiro o outro tem mais amor ou
não e aí que eu entro e eu que há três
anos atrás
agora parece que o tempo parou em dois
anos mas foi quase há três anos atrás
estava no brasil
nunca parei gama uma vida aparentemente
normal estudava trabalhava praticava
desporto ea vida para uma partida
no espaço de uma semana fiquei sem andar
tinha uma inflamação na medula
o termo mais técnico técnico é minha lei
transversa os médicos até hoje não sabem
exatamente porque e fiquem nesta
cadeirinha sentava nessa minha nova
relegava e uma realidade que aos olhos
de muita gente e eu compreendo que seja
uma realidade que não tem nada pra seja
feliz e eu compreendo porquê porque a
minha limitação é muito visível ela anda
comigo pra todo lado
não é como se eu tivesse por exemplo do
primeiro deixava a minha opção zinho em
casa guardada e eu espero um carro
ninguém tem que ver com o estudo
primeira mas a mim toda a gente sempre
vê a minha cadeira eo crédito com muita
gente principalmente quem não conhece
que olhe pra mim e penso logo à cabeça
em capacidade dependência infelicidade
se algum de vocês aqui quando olhou pra
mim pensou em alguma dessas palavras eu
não estou aqui todos os professores
sentem mal não estou aqui para vos dizer
que vocês estão errados em capacidade ao
cair só é capaz de andar
é um facto que vai impor novas
tecnologias ainda uns passinhos e
acredito que cada vez mais independência
sou com certeza mais tendendo com muitos
de vocês às vezes até pelas
infraestruturas que temos aí mas não sou
dependente ao ponto de me empurraram a
cadeira sem perguntarem se eu preciso
ouvir um carregar no botão do valor
porque acham que eu não consigo toda uma
cadeira de rodas e sim essas coisas já
aconteceram influenciam as pessoas olham
pra mim e muitas vezes acreditam que sua
influência
mais uma vez de estão errados eu assisti
uma miséria e digo que sou muito mais
fui sódio do que era há três anos atrás
e não não venho para aqui dizer isto sei
explicar porque é que eu digo isto o que
a cavaleira me trouxe e o que a galera
me ensinou em primeiro lugar adaptar
adaptação
a todos nós todos vocês têm uma
capacidade de se adaptar às adversidades
que vocês próprios desconhecem
nós muitas vezes felizmente ou
infelizmente só nos apercebemos nossas
capacidades nos adaptar às situações e
combater as necessidades quando estamos
nelas e agora eu estreei um favorito
colaborar em mim e todos que cruzarem a
perna que conseguir cruzar hora de
cruzar a perna como fazem num banco de
areia e agora se não vencer vou usar a
minha perna e descruzar a minha perna
escravo ou trabalho a galera vai em que
não pediram pra mim falar aqui há dois
anos atrás não estar aqui uns bons dois
minutos para fazer o que acaba de fazer
coisas corriqueiras da nossa vida como
cruzar a perna e eu fiquei eu achava vou
tirar uma foto na cadeira fica muito
melhor quando a perna cruzada no chão
trabalho como dava dois anos atrás fazer
isto que agora faço praticamente
automático e falta cruzar a perna com
falta investir como faltou maior ganho
com falta entrar e sair do carro
são coisas que no início não gostaram
tanto e que hoje faz praticamente sem
pensar por que me adaptar e isso leva a
um outro ensinamento que a minha
carreira me trouxe paciência
essa galerinha fez me pensar que
paciência e claramente não era uma das
minhas qualidades nem das minhas
virtudes e acredito que também basta
andarmos no trânsito deverá conter as
pessoas que conduziam um sonho de muita
gente tamanho e esta cadeira pra mim é
uma ter paciência ter paciência de fazer
coisas que antes demoravam um minuto
como curtir umas calças nem isso
passaram a morar 52 minutos quando tenho
a minha lesão parece me que morava
paciência para para fazer pequenas
coisas de uma forma mais morava e
perceber que com paciência eu ia voltar
a conseguir fazer as coisas quase tão
rápido hoje em dia acho que o igual no
quadro do time nos tirar as calças
quando andava além de ter paciência a
cadeira ensinou uma das coisas mais
importantes que é o não ter vergonha não
ter medo de pedir ajuda e uma rapariga
como jardins independente vivia sozinha
ava não perder ninguém por perto mas
numa situação do evento é que tem que
pedir ajuda e tanto joga hoje em dia
continua até o primeiro jogo por capas
aí que eu não consigo subir a rampa que
eu não consigo subir há coisas que eu
não consiga ultrapassar mas no início
tinha que pedir ajuda para coisas
simples que não conseguiu efetivamente
fazer sozinha e pedir ajuda para que um
dia eu consiga fazer sozinha e é isso
essa capacidade hoteleira me deu de
perder o medo e prender o orgulho do
primeiro de pedir ajuda porque também
sou escorpiana em vista que são
orgulhosos e eu sou o e trouxe um nome
um dado que o que eu acredito ser muito
importante que muitas vezes falta muita
gente porque nós todos vivemos em
sociedade muitas vezes deixamos de fazer
coisas porque não temos a coragem não
temos a humildade de pedir ajuda para
vocês esta altura do campeonato eu vou
eu assumir mais uma vez que estão a
pensar em mim então vou pensar ok e
pronto quando for uma coisa chata é pra
não dizer outra coisa mas ela tá aqui
com um discurso positivo mas então ela
não voltou
ela não perguntou sei lá porque ela
porque tem mais vou vencer pra vocês a
minha volta
nunca foi por ter deixado andar nunca eu
voltava porque estava com as sete meses
internada motivo todas as
intercorrências que vocês possam pensar
no hospital eu devo era um cateter de
toda hora eu já não vinha a informar e
eu já não podia ver as cataratas é isso
sim eu tenho volta para a empresa
mostrou muito social
aí eu tenho volta mas nunca foi por ter
deixado o plenário enquanto a célebre
pergunta tinha porquê a mim que muitas
pessoas não fazem e nunca um pergunta
isso eu só um confronto com essa
pergunta quando as pessoas me fazem essa
pergunta a catarina não pensa porque é
porque te ea minha resposta é sempre a
mesma e vai continuar certo porque não a
mim
nós somos tanta gente neste mundo
neste segundo que nós estamos aqui todos
estão a acontecer coisas tão mais alguém
e tão boas outra pessoa porque não a mim
obviamente que as pessoas têm a vida
facilitada a mim tem uma tela uma rifa
ter que deixar andar para aprender uma
turma uma série de coisas
os pouco não amem outros ensinamentos
que acabaram me trouxe foi este é
difícil de explicar mas acho que vou
conseguir a importância de vivermos o
presente
se vocês pensarem o ser humano
todos nós em nossa sociedade vem muito
do viver no passado e no futuro nós
vivemos ou da soldado ou da memória do
que já foi
obviamente que eu tenho saudades andar
não vou ser hipócrita tem seu lado de
correr
tenho saudades de ir a um restaurante e
não pensar em sua história em escravas e
se eu vou precisar da ajuda se
instalando em casa vai adaptada a essa
casa de banho não vai estar ocupada por
alguém se deu estar mais à vontade para
fazer coisas que não quero fazer outra
casa de banho para para não pensar eu
vou estar aqui tem lugar pra mim lugar
do estacionamento com o meu carro não
vai estar ocupado por alguém se viu pará
lei dois minutinhos e estão isolados em
estudo mas é um movimento disso estamos
no passado estamos no futuro o futuro do
que vai ser a que vai ser daqui uma
semana como é que eu vou sustentar isto
é como eu vou entregar até o trabalho
viver a sociedade do fundo do passado ou
do do futuro eu lembro foi também tudo
ia em que o pulso em prática na minha
vida eu viver o presente
eu estava no carro manhã meu amor
maternal é péssimo e se ele estava muito
mal também estava a chover eu estava com
os meus pais no carro estava irregular
estava mesmo ao esporte já estavam se
para uma série de desgraças que iam
acontecer
meu pai é ter a minha carreira isso
olhar eu ia chegar à faculdade de chá
cavar com as costas molhadas a roupa
toda suja e pensei para para catarina
para a imprensa
o next acho o carro que tinha seus pais
estão aqui tão bons ou outros irmãos
também tu vais popular vai aprender
dessa possibilidade que muita gente não
tem e não consigo explicar eu só não saí
porque efetivamente não consegui saltar
mas é o sensação de tranqüilidade que o
nível do viver aqui é um presente como
nós agora estamos todos aqui neste
momento empreendimentos nossos problemas
os meus neste momento aqui neste momento
nós estamos todos bem e isso traz-nos é
isso é viver pra mim não é porque alguma
forma nosso futuro está com condicionado
é por que viver o presente pra mim é
eleitoralmente viver ea cadeira ensinam
muito isso
por último mas não menos importante a
cadeira ensinou me que qualquer um de
vocês é a melhor forma de você como
bater em alguma adversidade é seguir em
frente
seguir continuar só se pensarem na
prática o que é confuso adianta lamentar
vos lamentar lamentar chorar ok eu não
vou ser hipócrita 56 em catarina todos a
fitas que chorar 5 litros de lágrimas e
o durante um ano só posso lamentar que
vai voltar a andar
se calhar considerava uma desidratação
chorava ou chicletes lágrimas lutavam
ano lamentar-me voltar a andar
mas eu sei que isso não vai acontecer
neste momento eu sei que nem isto essa
vontade que eu tenho de voltar a andar
não pode comandar a minha vida quem
comanda a minha vida sou eu e foi isso
que eu fiz eu seguir em frente na minha
nova realidade cria um canal no youtube
foi completamente pretensioso e que
entretanto conseguiu ajudar tanta gente
com uma coisa que aparentemente é mau e
pra mim trouxe tantas coisas boas eu
ponho música com uma amiga voltou e com
música ironicamente é primeira vez que
teve por música minha amiga não estava
cá estava no brasil eu tive que pôr
música naquela área sozinho e eu pensei
não somente é vida já não vai lá
catarina já não agüenta suficiente força
da minha visão estava num curso kan não
acreditava e ou melhor eu não conseguia
entender pra mim que não estava a fazer
fluir mas não estava e de tanto ter medo
da opinião dos outros de o estado uma
carreira tão promissora vai desistir e
não sei q tava ensina e entrei porque
quis mas não estava feliz foram precisos
dois anos depois da cadeira para eu
perceber que não estava feliz e queria
mudar e hoje me dói e sabem que os
outros pensam da minha mudança
eu também não só isso e sabem o que é
melhor eu não quero saber
eu precisava de outros oito minutos
o tempo de outros oito minutos aqui pra
falar com vocês para vocês perceberem
que esperar muito vocês sabem o que é
acordar todos os dias e pensar que vou
fazer uma coisa que eu gosto por mim que
estou feliz por mim quando estava a
preparar a apresentação e eu tive a
curiosidade de pesquisar sempre essa via
alguns artigos científicos sobre a
felicidade que fugira talvez já tenha
perguntado que ela foi ensinada e há um
sócio - eu não sabia e procurei vindo no
mineirão quase como em todos
um dos fatores que as pessoas
identificavam como importante para serem
feliz por isso
era o respeito deve ser respeitada mas
eu concordo e ao vento que nesta
situação eu ainda tenho que lutar todos
os dias mais para ser respeitada no
senado como um membro ativo como membro
com voz e como mesmo sobre os
funcionários simplesmente não anda
mas o resto é tudo igual também ter as
mesmas oportunidades mesmo de ver os
mesmos direitos e relativa à ok
há exatamente assim é que agora vai
afastar e eu estou tentando ensinar
já saí mas eu penso em outra coisa
peço que respeitem e respeitem a minha
felicidade
a felicidade na cadeira e com a cadeira
porque esta minha felicidade aqui não é
uma máscara não é uma farsa não é alguma
coisa que eu fiz todos os dias a
afluência
ela é sou eu é eu sou feliz por ter
partilhado este momento com você e eu
sou humanamente flu isso e
realisticamente feliz
o que isso quer dizer que eu não estou
todos os dias pois esse é uma mensagem
que eu quero que vocês levem deste
minutos que estiveram aqui comigo e que
a partir de agora quando olham por favor
para uma pessoa na cadeira com alguma
limitação física seja ela o que for leve
essa mensagem
esta minha cadeira em nenhum momento me
prendeu a minha cabeça em nenhum momento
no ime tom
a minha carreira liberta obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]